you were emotional basically for what an
hour there's like an hour of that movie
where you're just crying screaming
yelling amazed how did you keep kind of
the frenzy of it it's kind of quite the
opposite actually
oh I mean it was the most exposing
performance base I've ever been in and I
you know to be still like that you know
it kind of it takes a great director to
to give you a confidence to be so still
and so open and so I said it wrong I
guess so what you were being was open
not in yeah yeah you know unlike most of
the stuff you've seen me do you know a
script like this you know was what you
know I've been searching for for a
really long time there's meat to the
bone you know I'm not playing some goofy
best friend or some funny sidekick or
something like that it you know it's
it's it's a really harrowing journey and
he's a very behind his charm
he's a very jaded young man who has a
lot of guilt to bear but how so talk a
little bit again about how what is it
I'm just curious not being an actor
about that about that stillness and I
know looking at Rooney Mara I see and
I've seen her in many performances where
she does that too it's kind of like or
even I would say if you've seen that is
about who pair and L this season if they
if you've seen that that kind of that
kind of stillness with everything behind
the eyes yeah I mean it was some they
started well yeah so I had to audition
for this one really hard actually yeah
and yeah it's funny when your resume
kind of works against you and you wait a
minute this is a you know you become an
obvious choice and so you have to go in
the room and prove yourself and you know
I put myself on tape when I was in LA
and then
what did you did you tape a specific
year three three big scenes as a kind of
argument with this with Lucy's Bruni's
character and a couple of other scenes
one or two which never made it to the
film and then I went and did a six-hour
audition just before I went to shoot us
prepping for this phone call the man who
knew infinity right working on this
Indian accent for a long time and then
they call me and say Garth wants to meet
you next week and I'm like ah am I gonna
do this so I'm online searching and
doing all watching all these videos
that's you know Saru does ease life
talks and it was I went in and we spent
six hours in the room together and at
five and a half hours Garth goes I want
you to before you go I want you to raw
it's like you must be kidding
and he's that now I just want you to
scream I'm gonna put some music on and I
want you to expel music well if this is
the thing so he goes I want you to expel
any sort of pain or anguish you're
feeling and I want you to just
completely be free for me to mold you
and he's that kind of director that
slowly breaks you down piece for piece
and then builds you back together again
and he put on this song and it's by it's
actually a soundtrack from Babel caught
earth by a composer called Gustavo
Center night
oh yes but it's called deportation it's
a beautiful stirring kind of strings
tune and I was listening to that on the
way to the audition and it was just this
serendipity when he put it on us oh my
god and we went through this space and
he just kind of talking to me in the
moment you know like you can feel your
mother you can see your brother in front
of you we went through this whole
journey together and you know as soon as
I got the role he said look I want you
to come in to a performance space that
you've never been before we don't want
to see that kid from Slumdog we want you
to grow up you know and so I it was
eight months I called up my manager and
said don't send me anything for the next
day months I want to fully commit every
fiber of my being to getting this
journey right because I don't get roles
like this it's a fact yes so anyway to
finish that off it was the
it was it was eight months of the
physical training the accident and all
that and then I went to India three
weeks before we started filming and that
was when I started to travel the trains
and I would watch the landscape change
and I I basically was doing a pilgrimage
as a character and trying to trace those
footsteps I wrote Diaries I went to the
orphanages and you know goth would give
me these very strange exercises like
staring in front of a mirror for an hour
and yeah you feel like an idiot
it's strange because you know the first
two minutes is excruciating because
you're used to combing your hair or
popping a pimple or doing something and
then all of a sudden you find this
dullness and you just look at yourself
and then something crazy happened where
I started talking to myself I started
crying and then I just couldn't
recognize the person in that mirror I I
saw my father for a second then my
mother and I went to set visibly shaken
the next day I was like goth what the
hell I'm a fake I'm a fraud I don't know
who I am and he's like that's it that's
the point you know you know this is just
a shell but your soul is ever-changing
and that's what we're here to do is
capture this soulful performance so I
need you to and Danny ball always used
to say that to me I came in from Skinz
and you know as a supporting character
you can display attributes you know it's
you can do that you can be loud but you
know to lead something in a certain way
he goes I need you to be still so the
audience can enter you through your eyes
beyond this journey with you and it's
been a long time since I was able to be
able to step into that's
performance-based again so it's and that
is because it's hard to get leading
roles is that I mean you kind of um
everyone talks about typecast and all
that blah blah Blee I mean it's everyone
faces a stereotype you can be a
beautiful woman and you're gonna face a
box you know I finish Slumdog and that
was the first film I had ever done and
it was such a beautiful experience and
then I stepped out to an ocean of
nothing there was nothing there you know
as a young 16 17 year old kid you like
okay I want to get my teeth stuck into
some more work I'm ready after I've got
a taste and you had this huge I remember
interviewing you
what kind of situation like this right
after Slumdog and you were like a puppy
like you had all this energy and you
were hugely excited because you were
part of this big this is before the
Oscar you were kind of part of this big
thing that was bound to get an award
yeah I mean yeah it was bigger than any
any sense yeah and from you know from
there there was nothing to follow up
with and so there was a choice do I do
why not work or do I try and work and
and take what's out there so I can keep
the tool shop so I can learn about the
craft and I chose the latter and I
thought my motto was gonna be to
sometimes the only way to break the mold
is to take it on you know and slowly as
it you're in that space you can inject a
difference and with each role I've done
I've tried to shift the bar a little bit
until you know a film like this comes
out you get to play a really modern
young man I've not got an Indian accent
you know that the role is split into two
there's a young boy Sonny Pawar who's
absolutely incredible and you know they
did they cast him first they cast you
first and then find him he's a miracle
yeah completely hehehe it's kind of like
a movie that first III yeah well um
Sonny was picked from 2000 kids he'd
never been in front of a camera before
and yeah his is a perfect namesake he's
a ray of sunshine and you know he said
be playing on any day you know it
doesn't really understand the the art of
acting and there's a real purity to it
and Garth is this guy that you know he
puts him in those train stations and
shoots from a long lens and people are
actually ignoring this boy he's
screaming for his mother as you we see
it and commuters are just brushing past
them and it's it's he was great you know
but uh sorry what was the question
yeah you know it's funny they match you
the question I believe was did they
match you did they hire him first or you
first
I got hide first and then I went to
India and I saw him doing you know play
hide and seek with like 30 kids from the
streets that they'd found and it's to
find this sort of playfulness and energy
are liked and Sonny Sonny really
possesses that and he's actually to be
able to grasp such adult situations to
wrap your head around that and also hats
off to the two actors he's in the ring
with you know Priyanka Bose and Abhishek
they actually have been in front of a
camera before and they set the
atmosphere so that he can play in it
that's very important to recognize you
know they and goth would do things with
a dop to leave the camera running so
who'd call cut and they'll keep it
recording and that's when he said and he
would lie on his brother's shoulder and
that's it that's the moment right yeah
so they don't do things like that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]